welcome back to the amber reference show
now americans are constantly hearing
about our enormous immigration crisis
but what if i told you that we
actually don't have an immigration
crisis like at all let me explain in a
segment called how did we get here
according to a certain kind of person
the kind who would rather have guns in
schools than black history america's
problems boil down to one thing
undocumented immigrants at least that's
what i call them conservatives call them
illegal aliens which is an offensive
term and in 1607 real americans called
them who the hell are all these white
people and why don't they season their
thanksgiving dinner
now when people rant about immigration
they're usually making one of three
complaints first they say there are too
many immigrants next they'll call them
criminals and finally they'll say
they're stealing our elections the only
people more demonized than undocumented
immigrants are people who emerged from
the pandemic total eject
we had an agreement that involved wine
and soft pants you betrayed me donna
but what if none of these things are
true let's start with the first one
there's too many of them well people are
worried that america will be overrun
with immigrants and we don't have enough
resources to deal with them which sounds
reasonable but what if i told you that
the number of unauthorized immigrants in
the u.s has declined since 2007 is true
undocumented immigrants have been
decreasing for over a decade much like
the number of people doing parkour or
the age of leonardo dicaprio's
girlfriends
now
i know what you're thinking but what
about all that footage of immigrant
caravans coming to the border were they
just a soul train line
first of all i wish and yes
some people are immigrating here from
other countries illegally but people are
also crossing the border in the opposite
direction that is how borders work and
for years more immigrants have been
leaving america than coming in so
technically it's immigrants who solved
our immigration problem it's like if you
found out that the hamburglar was
sneaking into mcdonald's every night and
leaving a bunch of hamburgers
now let's move on to the next concern
that undocumented immigrants are drug
smugglers terrorists or criminals now i
group these three together because
they're all equal parts [ __ ] first
the vast majority of drug traffickers
are u.s citizens the drug trade much
like a combination taco bell pizza hut
kfc is
ridiculously american
and
while there definitely are mexican drug
cartels they're using way more
sophisticated methods than asking people
to frickin jog across the border
recent investigations show that they've
used planes drones and even an
underground rail system with solar
powered lighting
they have a solar-powered subway meaning
meanwhile in new york city we got this
we'd be lucky to get a mexican drug
cartel in here maybe they can get the f
train to run on time
undocumented immigrants also aren't
terrorists in fact trump's own state
department said there's no credible
information that any member of a
terrorist group has traveled through
mexico to gain access to the united
states zero terrorists that is the
smallest number you can have
even back to the future had a couple of
terrorists and that's just a movie about
not making out with your own mom
so
immigrants aren't drug kingpins or
terrorists but how many of them commit
regular crimes well i've said before
that crime is related to education and
economics not race or ethnicity but
there's one group that totally defies
that research do you know who
juggalos i'm kidding
it's undocumented immigrants because
undocumented immigrants have
considerably lower crime rates than
native born citizens basically it goes
undocumented immigrants american
citizens and then any famous person who
appears in the first 10 minutes of law
and order
like
you know if mark ruffalo is playing the
mailman girl he did it
but it gets better because immigrants
don't just not commit crimes they
actually make neighborhoods safer one
study found a reduction of almost five
violent crimes for every one percent
increase in the foreign-born population
so if you want to improve your
neighborhood don't add three coffee
shops in an overpriced cheese store at
immigrants
so that just leaves the final question
are undocumented immigrants stealing
elections the short answer no
the long answer hell no
so why do people think they are well in
2014 in 2014 a group called the
cooperative congressional election study
conducted a survey about voting now at
the bottom was a box that asked people
if they were american citizens the
surveyors knew that inevitably a few
people would check the wrong box and
that's what happened they got a small
number of voters who checked the box
saying they weren't citizens now what's
more likely that a few people checked
the wrong box or that they decided to
use a random survey to confess to a
felony
either way conservatives used that very
small number to declare that this study
meant that millions of people voted
illegally in 2008 and that same
misinformation has been repeated ad
nauseam to say the 2020 election was
stolen as well but just for fun want to
know how many confirmed illegal votes
they actually found in that original
2014 survey
five
yeah much like a guy in a locker room
telling people how many women he's had
sex with the republicans took the number
five and pretended it was millions
so
to summarize numbers of undocumented
immigrants have been decreasing for
years
immigrants aren't criminals and they
aren't stealing elections more
importantly these false accusations say
a lot more about white people's fears of
people that don't look like them than
they do about immigrants but pretending
that those fears constitute a national
crisis well much like a taco bell pizza
hut kfc that couldn't be more american
this has been how did we get here
[Music]
you